[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE PAYNE: Hey,
welcome everybody.
My name is Dave Payne
from Elastifile.
Excited to be with
you guys today.
We'll be talking about POSIX
file systems, enterprise class
storage in Google Cloud.
I'm honored to be joined
by a couple of good friends
here today.
We've got Naidu
Annamaneni from eSilicon.
NAIDU ANNAMANENI:
Yeah, I am CIO,
responsible for [INAUDIBLE]
CIO, responsible for strategy,
software development, IT
operations at eSilicon.
DAVE PAYNE: And Dean Hildebrand
is joining us from Google.
DEAN HILDEBRAND: Hello, my
name is Dean Hildebrand.
I'm in the office of the CTO,
and one of my goals at Google
is to make file storage
awesome in Google Cloud.
DAVE PAYNE: That is great.
All right, well, we've got a
few minutes together today.
We're going to jump in
to some high-level stuff,
and then we're going to
get deep and go technical.
I assume that's why you're here.
With a title like this, if
this is attractive to you,
you're a hardcore nerd.
And we thought we'd serve
up some meat in this session
today.
OK?
So let us get through
a few slides of intro,
and I promise we'll
deliver some real demos
in the middle of the section.
And Dean and Naidu are
going to stand up and share
some of their perspective and
real-world experience doing
this in Cloud.
OK?
So first of all, there's
a great concept in tech
that you've probably
seen floating around
for a while called yak shaving.
I learned about this
last year, actually,
at Google, Google Cloud Next.
It's this idea that--
we all get caught up in it.
Right?
A yak shaving is, you
start out to do something
big and important, and
then a day later you've
done everything else but
that, because there's
all these dependencies.
Right?
It's the last in a series
of unexpected steps.
I read it came from this
idea that rice harvesters,
they would go out to
harvest the year's harvest,
and they'd use the yaks to
pull the carts in and out.
But they would find that
the yak grew all this hair
in the middle of the
winter, and so they
couldn't fit through the gates.
So they'd have to turn
around and go back and do
a bunch of yak shaving to
get the yak skinny enough
to go through the gate.
Right?
And I've heard it
said in IT, in tech,
this is essentially
what our job is.
Does anyone shave yaks
all day long for a living?
I know I do.
In fact, preparing
this presentation,
the demos included a lot of
yak shaving for me, so much so
that it made me an even
bigger believer in Cloud,
to be honest.
But you know yak
shaving comes up
in all of our lives
in different ways.
I was throwing a party
for my wife last year,
and I ended up spending three
weeks rebuilding a deck.
You go to buy the electric
car, which I haven't done yet,
but as you do, you find
out that you're now
pulling 220 volt
into your garage,
and it doesn't quite fit.
And it's a big bunch of hassle.
You say, I'm going
to go have children.
You have these amazing ideas
of graduations and weddings,
and it's just fantastic.
And then for 18 years it's this
and this and this and this,
and finally they get tired
after eating all the bologna.
So that happens in
all parts of life,
and especially as you start
to consider a move to Cloud.
You know, you finally
make that decision.
A guy like Naidu,
as a CIO, says,
we've got a mandate from our
board, our CEO, whatever.
We're going to go
all in on Cloud.
We're ready to make this happen.
He says to you guys, make it so.
And then you find that,
hey, changing infrastructure
is hard.
There's a lot of yaks
that have to be shaved
to make the stuff that
I comfortably use inside
of my data center work in Cloud.
Right?
Specifically in this
talk, we're going
to hit some of these issues as
it relates to applications that
need things like
NFS, which seems
like a simple, mundane,
tried-and-true method
of accessing data.
But it's different,
because everything in Cloud
is a little bit different.
I can't just take my NAS and
put it out there and work.
It doesn't work that way.
The fundamentals are different.
I need to get my data out there.
Well, data formats
are different.
The files may be the same,
but there's different ideas
like object and the like.
How do I get my data
up there, upload it,
keep the POSIX nature
of the data the same.
So lots of other issues come up.
And that's what we'll start
addressing here today.
OK?
So we came together,
us, Dean and I,
essentially, in our
respective companies,
to eliminate those
yaks that have
to be shaved as you start to
make this intro into Cloud.
OK?
We good?
So today we're going to cover,
again, a little more theory.
Dean's going to come
up in just a second
and tell you the
perspective that Googlers
have on NFS in Cloud.
We're going to show you how
some of this stuff works,
demo it, and then Naidu's going
to be-- he's our headliner.
So you got to stick
around to see Naidu.
He'll come and show you the
real work that he and his team
have done.
And by the way, some of
his team is out here.
We've got David and Jonas.
Yeah, raise your hand, guys.
They can't see you on the video,
but they're in the audience.
As any technical questions
come up, they can answer it.
They're experts.
All right?
So without further ado, I'd
like to hand the mic over
to Dean Hildebrand and
let him take it away.
Dean?
DEAN HILDEBRAND: Thanks, Dave.
All right.
So I wanted to just give a
brief intro on a few things.
One, just talking briefly
about file in the Cloud,
and as well as, why does Google
care about file in the Cloud?
All right, so here's
the typical scenario.
A company is going to
move into the Cloud.
All right.
This sounds awesome.
Google has a bunch of
application migration tools.
All right.
Let's move the applications
into the Cloud.
Next step is, well, what
do we do with the storage?
Are we going to
start from scratch?
rethink everything
we ever thought about storage?
Does the Cloud solve
all of our problems?
What are we going to do?
So I think that this becomes a
general blocker in many cases
when you have
terabytes to petabytes
or more data on premise,
and you're just not sure,
not only where to store
it, but how to store it,
and how your applications
will access it.
So I think some of the
no-nos generally are--
there is no one thing.
So object storage,
GCS, it's awesome,
and I'm going to talk
briefly about it.
It's not a requirement
by any means.
You can't say, oh, I
can't move to Cloud
because my workload doesn't use
object storage, or something
to that effect.
It doesn't work that way, right?
We want to make
sure the matching is
great to your application.
The other one is, we don't
want to look at, well,
look at those customers
that are on stage.
They used this storage solution.
That's the one I have to use.
Well, I mean, you could
have completely different
applications, right?
So really I think we need
to ignore all that hype,
and then think about more just,
what do your applications need?
Just focus on the applications
that you're running.
How are they running today on
what the existing systems are,
and then what do they
need in the Cloud?
So what can we modernize,
and where does innovation
and new things make sense?
And where does just using
what you're doing today
to make a lot of sense?
All right.
So GCS-- GCS is awesome.
People always ask,
well, why aren't you
pushing people into GCS?
And the point is is that,
well, many applications just
don't fit the model.
And so the POSIX
API is one of them.
But even if you put the
POSIX API on top of GCS,
there's still a million
other requirements
where object storage as a
concept in which it's been
implemented just doesn't fit.
It has long latency times,
no in-place updates,
small random reads.
It can be really tricky in
terms of how you're doing them.
And you can always copy them
into the individual nodes
and process them there,
but if your dataset
is larger than what you
can process in a single VM,
you run yourself into
trouble, as well.
So let's go back to think
about NFS again, and see
how that can fit.
But I talk to some people
that are like, well,
NFS, I've been using
NFS, and it's slow.
Why are you telling me
to use NFS in the Cloud?
I'm very confused on this thing.
Well, the point is,
is that NFS is modern.
It is Cloud-friendly, and
it does work really well.
There's no reason to dump
the baby with the bathwater
as they say.
NFS is built into all
of the VMs you deploy.
It works very well
with Kubernetes.
It's preemptible, very
friendly in the sense
that, just take your VM away.
Right?
NFS already stored
your data somewhere.
And in many ways
it's very scalable.
It can support tens of
thousands of cores, as well
as it's familiar to your
IT administration staff.
And so that's something
where we really
think we have something
that we can build upon.
The problem, though, is today,
NFS in the Cloud I would argue
is in a very immature place.
And we're really just at
the beginning of the journey
to start thinking about,
well, maybe we don't need
to do it exactly the same way.
And maybe we need
to think about it
in a slightly different
manner than when we
were deploying it on-premise.
And so one of the things
is, open source storage
can be tricky.
Talk about yak
shaving-- there can
be a lot of yak shaving
in unmanaged open source
solutions.
The vendor ecosystem
is growing, and we're
doing our best to improve
it, but it's still
in its early stages.
And that's where
something becomes hard,
because a lot of
times you're having
to take a new chance on a
new vendor inside the Cloud.
And in a lot of cases, the
current NFS and file storage
options that you
can deploy, they
were designed for hardware.
And people are just doing
lift-and-shifts into the Cloud,
and they're not handling new
failure models, performance
characteristics, and how
the durability is managed.
And so it's really
something where
we want to rethink
about, let's use NFS,
but let's rethink about
how we're doing it.
So what we want is file
storage, manage and scale it
just like the Cloud does, but
drive it like an enterprise.
We want to make sure that
this is enterprise-ready.
So back to the point
of, why does Google
care, though, about this
stuff, this NFS stuff?
Well, you know, let's
look at EDA industry.
The industry was
at $8.5 billion.
It's growing over the next
six years to $14 billion.
And that's just the
software ecosystem itself.
And so that's not including
any of the IT infrastructure
underneath the covers
that's supporting it.
And so Google wants to
be that IT infrastructure
that is supporting this
multibillion dollar
industry under the
covers, and why we're
working with people like Naidu.
But that's just one
of many industries
where we're seeing
file as dominant,
and the software vendors would
have to completely rewrite
how they're doing things today.
And it's not even clear
that it's possible
even if they wanted to.
And so manufacturing, oil and
gas, higher education research,
financial services,
those quants that
are out there, health care,
genomics, and media, of course,
that you'll see a lot
here, as well-- and so all
of these industries are
built on file today,
and it's something
where we believe
that if we can make
file really easy
and well integrated
into the Cloud,
then this is something that
Google Cloud can really
leverage.
And so our mission
here at Google Cloud
is to make file storage awesome
and easy to use and just
as super cloud-integrated
as you would expect.
And that's why we're so excited
to work with people like Naidu
at eSilicon who's really
pioneering how EDA
can be done inside the cloud.
And that's what I have.
Back to you, Dave.
Thank you very much.
DAVE PAYNE: Thanks, Dean.
Let's hear it.
I'll take the clicker.
So let's-- what I wanted to do
then is show what this actually
looks like, and get out of
the slides a bit and show some
action.
And as brave as I am
about doing live demos--
it's one of my favorite things--
I recorded these just for
you so we can get straight
to the point and
cover a lot of topics
in a short amount of time.
So real briefly, let me tell you
a little bit about Elastifile.
We're kind of a new
company into the scene.
It came out of
stealth-mode last year.
We built a full stack storage
product as an NFS filer,
designed to work with
cloud principles,
but still show up like
you're used to in enterprise.
The idea that Dean was
talking about where
you're comfortable living
in your enterprise home.
Your application is built
there and it exists,
and the underlying
infrastructure is set.
We designed ours to be
compatible with that,
but also move
straight into cloud.
And I'll show you what
that looks like as we go.
So some simple things
that we allow you to do--
one is just take high
performance NFS applications
and run them as-is in Cloud.
All of these semantics work
the way that you would expect.
I'll show some of that in a bit.
But we have it show
up inside of Google
so your applications can just
lift, shift, and start running.
Second is, we have some
capabilities to take advantage
of the different types of
storage inside of Google
without forcing you
to deal with it.
So there's storage
inside of Compute Engine,
there's storage inside
of Cloud Storage.
And we have the ability to
move data back and forth
and tier them without
breaking POSIX semantics
and the single
namespace and things
like that that matter
to your applications.
And then lastly, the
data mobility side of it,
we have a capability
called CloudConnect
that moves full datasets.
We take snapshots of data
and ship them as a whole
back and forth so you can keep
your data integrity intact,
but have it show up and
use it where you want it.
So think about giving
lift to datasets
that tend to have a
lot of gravity in them
due to the nature of data.
So these are the two components
I'll be talking about
back and forth.
On the far side is
the file system.
This is a full-stack,
scale-out file system,
so it presents
like an NFS server,
but it's fully distributed.
It's a shared-nothing,
write-anywhere architecture.
So as we need to scale
capacity and performance,
the scaling unit is a
node, a little server.
And that they just add
dynamically, laterally,
as you need more.
And as you don't need it as
much, it constricts back in.
So it's very elastic.
And it actually works to
add and take away on demand.
And then in Cloud,
what's magic about Cloud
is, you can instantiate
anything at the drop of a hat.
So we can stand up
an Elastifile cluster
in mere minutes, the kind of
thing you wouldn't do on prem.
You wouldn't stand up a filer
on a whim, on an afternoon
do a project and
then throw it away.
That's typically a
five-year process, right,
that we can shrink down
into a couple of minutes.
And then lastly, CloudConnect
is a companion technology
as part of our stack.
And this is about reaching
out to datasets that don't
live inside of Elastifile yet.
So CloudConnect can connect to
an existing filer or whatever
that might be, grab the data,
take a complete snapshot of it
that's identical
to what you have,
all of the POSIX data,
anything about the namespace--
attributes,
hardlinks, softlinks--
it keeps all that intact,
compresses it, dedupes it
and moves it into Cloud Storage,
and makes it ready for action
as a file system later.
OK?
So that's what CloudConnect is.
I didn't take time to add
a demo of CloudConnect
into this session.
We did one yesterday
that was fantastic
that I'll show you a link to.
And I encourage
you go on YouTube,
watch some videos
about it, and you
can contact us to download
and use this tool.
But essentially it's
a connection point
between file infrastructure
and object infrastructures.
You know, objects are
designed to store files
in a flat namespace.
So to create hierarchy and
logic in an object system,
you have to do that
yourself essentially.
Whereas a file system shows
up and it's ready to go.
I can create folders
and files, and it
all kind of self-organizes.
So CloudConnect bridges the
gap between those worlds.
Instead of using
objects as files,
each object is
essentially like a block.
And then we can
store chunks of files
across millions or
billions of objects,
and still maintain
a namespace that
allows us to take many
versions of a file system,
as many as you
like, and store it
in the smallest
compacted space possible.
So we can do lots of versions
of snapshots, compression
and dedupe, and it's a
really space-efficient and
cost-effective way to store data
that you're not really using.
And it's also the basis for
the tiering capabilities
that we have in the product.
OK?
So take a look at that.
There's a quick sneak
peek at the interface,
of different object
providers that it supports.
It's really designed to go
from any source to any target
and be a middleman
in between them, OK?
So take a look.
This session happened
yesterday with Jerome.
You can screen cap that
link and go watch it.
And there's a bunch of
videos on YouTube, as well.
OK?
So let's move on.
All right.
So inside of Google
Cloud there's
a couple of options for NFS.
There's a few, and
they're growing.
And really briefly, being
announced just a few weeks ago
is Filestore.
So I'm not going to spend
a lot of time on Filestore,
but it's a fully
managed file system.
You can get a file system
mount, pay as you go,
and start using it.
It has fixed boundaries in
terms of how big it gets,
but it seems like a
really great product.
On our side, where
Elastifile really fits
is for applications that need
the kind of really demanding
problems to solve,
whether it's demanding
in terms of capacity
or performance
or both, and some of
that dynamic nature
of those applications.
So Elastifile is
designed to grow
with you to whatever the
boundaries of your application
may be.
Unlimited is the
term that we use
and that we think about
as we design and architect
Elastifile.
OK?
And it's been great to work
closely with the Google team,
and take advantage
of some of the power
of that infrastructure
underneath
to really stretch what we
can do with this system.
So a little bit more
about ECFS, as we call it,
Elastifile Cloud File System.
First of all, like I
said, it's familiar.
You're going to find
an NFS interface that's
POSIX-compatible.
Other protocols we'll
probably introduced later
to make it even easier for you.
Second, it's elastic,
truly, scale out,
scale in as your needs demand.
There's a full API behind the
product, so every function
that we do, you can automate
it behind your automation
tool of choice,
whatever that may be.
It's fast, so we're
able to take advantage
of whatever underlying
infrastructure we attach to.
So we attach to raw disks
inside of our nodes,
and we can take advantage
of persistent disks,
persistent SSD, local SSD,
and even Cloud Storage,
and then take advantage
of those and make
them available as a single
pool of usable capacity.
And so that choice allows us
to get really cost-effective.
You can match the
storage infrastructure
to the cost nature of
whatever your problem is,
and get the right amount
of performance out of it,
and change your mind.
It's like, again, instantiate
quickly and tear it back down.
You can deploy 18
clusters a day.
It's all good.
It's flexible, so this stuff
can show up where you need it.
You know, Google is always
offering more and more places
to compute all around the world.
We can follow them around.
And then lastly,
the last two points
I wanted to drive home before
we jump into the demos, a.,
it's Cloud native,
meaning this was designed
with the semantics of
Cloud in mind as opposed
to that of on-prem.
And the world is
a lot different.
You don't see the
infrastructure in the same way
when you're running in Cloud.
The interrupts are different.
The failures look different.
They're not hardware
failures we're dealing with.
They're more logical
failures in the stack.
And essentially you
designed expecting failures
to occur all the time.
So there are
different principles
that you have to
bring to the table.
We've designed for that.
And then lastly, Dean
mentioned open source
versus supported products.
We're a full company
supporting these products
with 224/7 support,
continual updates.
When you're bringing
enterprise into Cloud,
you need that sort of comfort
to be wrapped around it
so everything just works,
and you can meet your SLA
as we meet our SLA to you.
OK?
All right.
So getting started, I'm
going to show this working.
If you want to start--
in fact, if you're bored of my
presentation, follow this link
or go into Cloud Console.
Look in the marketplace.
Search for Elastifile.
If you can't remember how to
spell that, search for NFS.
And you'll see two options we
have up in the marketplace now.
We have our file system.
Click Deploy.
As long as you have a
project, you can go.
You'll be up and running.
Answer a couple of
questions, and you'll
be able to store
data in minutes.
And then below
that, we're excited,
we just released this last week,
is our storage provisioner.
This is our connection
into Kubernetes.
And so if you have a
Kubernetes, a GKE cluster
running in Cloud, click,
button, button, button,
and you're going to be
deploying NFS storage
to store stateful data
from your containers.
And I'll show you a
bit of that, as well.
In fact, Jerome's
session I mentioned
goes into a deep dive
on that topic yesterday.
OK?
But once you're deployed,
you hit our console,
it runs right out
of Google Cloud.
And then any
application you have
that needs this can
just start working.
All right?
Let's show this stuff in action.
So demo topology I'm working
with today on the top
is a project inside
a CloudPlatform.
I have our file system deployed.
I've got a few standard Linux
clients running on CentOS.
I have a Google Kubernetes
engine cluster running.
And that's already deployed.
And then I'll be running
different applications
from there.
CloudConnect
connects the object.
And then lastly, I have
an on-prem data center
that's connected through a VPN
tunnel to my private project,
as well.
All right, so storage--
performance.
Everyone talks
about performance.
I did a couple of
performance demos for you
just to get that off the table.
We claim to be
high-performance storage,
and able to meet the needs
essentially where you are.
So let me show you a couple
of different profiles
I thought might be
interesting, and then I'll
shift into some of the
functionality of how
this stuff works out there, OK?
So three workloads--
one's a transactional
IO is one type of a workload.
You might think databases,
or lots of small files, lots
of changes and the like.
Elastifile was designed to be
a transactional file system.
We excel in this area, where
a lot of other file systems
you would think, this
isn't what you use NFS for.
I wouldn't put an
Oracle database on NFS,
or MySQL or something.
Here you can.
So the demo I'm going
to show you starts here.
So I'm running a Kubernetes
environment on the top.
You'll see I'm going
to start adding
more and more containers.
And everyone it adds--
it's going quickly.
I'll go back so you can
see that a little faster.
And then-- there we go.
So the demos will go quick.
So as I add containers
and scale them,
you'll see
performance down here.
You've got throughput
measured in megabytes
to gigabytes per second.
You've got IOs, that's how
many transactions are happening
per second in
thousands, that's the K.
And then latency is
along the bottom.
And then up on the
right in the corner
you see how many connections
are to the file system.
That's how many NFS connections
are being instantiated.
So our objective with
this is to show you
that we can maintain a linear
performance profile as load
is added to this system.
So watch it one more time.
Here we go.
You see throughput going up.
You see-- this is really
an IO-driven workload.
So that hit about 300
or so thousand IOs.
All right.
Let's go to the next one.
Second profile-- large
file random read.
So you have big bulk files.
This might be media and
entertainment or genomics
or something, where you have
these massive media or image
files that need to
be loaded up quickly
for processing, whether
that's for AI or ML
or something else like that.
We'll show you how we do there.
So watch the throughput here.
We're trying to get to
gigabytes per second.
I'm time lapsing all of this to
not bore you with the details,
but this is about 10
minutes worth of loading.
And it hits about 5.2 gigabytes
per second in the end.
So this is a small cluster, this
kind of entry-level cluster.
If we need more, we
just keep adding more.
What do you want to get to--
10, 20, 50 gigabytes per second?
And we can just keep on going.
OK?
You'll see we only had 24
connections that we're already
pushing that much IO.
We're hitting bottlenecks
inside of the Kubernetes engine,
actually, where we need to
keep adding infrastructure
to introduce more
load to this system.
Lastly, the opposite,
large file writes.
So maybe I'm generating large
files, images and the like.
I need to push those
quickly down into my storage
persistence layer.
How fast can I do that?
So same infrastructure here.
We'll let this guy spin up.
You watch throughput again.
So as we're adding
more nodes, we're
pushing up to about a 10-gig
connection right about now.
So we found-- we're at 1.1.
So that ends up at
about 1.2 or so,
which is essentially a
full 10-gig connection.
So we found a saturation
point in that network.
So that's performance.
Everyone talks
about performance.
You've got to perform
to play, or you
can't qualify in this business.
But that's one of
many things that
matter when you're
taking an enterprise
application to Cloud.
All right?
So deployments--
Cloud is typically
designed to be
click-and-go, and not
worried about infrastructure.
So this shows you here
what a typical deployment
looks like with Elastifile.
You click on the button,
select your project,
tell it what network you want
to write on, and hit Deploy.
OK?
You're still using one
finger so far, essentially.
And then it'll
start rolling out.
If you've ever used
Deployment Manager,
it's very typical here.
All the components spin up.
On the far side or
over here you'll
see it gives you
unique credentials.
You can use a login
for the first time.
This is our console or GUI.
All of these functions, again,
are available through our API.
You tell it what kind of
stores you want to use--
local SSD, persistent SSD.
We've actually just added a
few more options to that list
just in the last
couple of weeks.
And in no time, once you
hit go this will spin up,
puts a few VMs out there
inside of your project,
and then those services are now
exposed and available to all
of the workloads you
have running in Cloud.
OK?
That's it.
That takes about five
minutes, and it's all done.
In fact, if you're into
automation, infrastructure
as code, and things like
Terraform or Ansible
and Puppet, we have options
there for you, as well.
We've got a Terraform,
essentially a cookbook, out
on GitHub.
You can go follow that link
to grab it or grab a solution
article out of our
website on how to do this.
In fact, I'll show you in
less than 60 seconds here.
We'll let this demo go, assuming
this one will play for us.
And that one is not playing.
Let's see if we can get it go.
All right.
It is so fast, you
can't even see it.
What you would
have seen is a lot
of code flying
through the screen.
You give it a
cookbook, you tell it
what your parameters
are, and deploys it.
And when you're done, it goes
and destroys it and cleans up
all of its mess from before.
Next, the storage provisioner.
This is the one
we're excited about.
We just launched this.
If you have Kubernetes, which
is containers that are designed
to be totally
stateless, but you find
that old applications-- not
old, but traditional apps
or in databases and the like--
you want to run as containers
and get the benefit
of compute, they
have a hard time
dealing with state.
You can store data
to a local machine,
but it's challenging when
you get into tens or hundreds
or thousands of
containers, and they need
to work off a common dataset.
This is what we're designed for
here, using standard NFS, which
comes out of the box working
with a container platform.
And this allows you to connect
it right into Kubernetes,
add a storage class.
It will show up as
Elastifile inside of GKE.
And now it's a
resource, where you
can do provisioning right to
us, straight from kubectl.
So there's a concept inside
of Elastifile called data
containers.
So a data container
is to files and data
what a compute container
is to your applications.
It's a bucket, or it
contains everything
as a file system or
a single namespace
that you can then manage
as a single entity.
So a container is where we
apply policies to your data,
underneath-the-cover things like
how much storage does it need?
We have services like dedupe
and compression built into that.
And so this demo will show the
creation of a data container.
Log into the console.
There's your dashboard, and
all the fancy storage stuff--
capacities, performance.
We hit the data container screen
and you'll see a bunch of DCs
in here.
Point and click, give it a name.
We'll be using this one in
the next couple of demos.
We'll turn on.
Turn on and off.
You can toggle dedupe and
compression on anytime
you like.
And then we set a size.
This is a dynamic size.
But this is what will show up.
The file system expects
to see a size when
you connect to your machine.
So that's it.
It's created.
Get some syntax to connect
to it at the standard mount.
Again, there's no
client-side stuff needed.
Standard NFS out of a VM works.
So then that's
what it looks like.
Behind the scenes,
you can see the layers
of policies of different
features we can add in--
replication,
snapshots, NFS exports.
And other features
we'll continually
add with our engineering
team out in Israel
will start to show up into
here as we continue down
our journey in Cloud.
You'll see down on the
bottom, I have the ability
to do user mappings.
This is NFS language here.
If you're used to NFS, this
is very familiar to you.
So here we're going
to export this share,
make it available to
just the machines inside
of my private network.
And now ready to go.
That's now being
exposed and advertised
and ready for consumption.
So let's see it at work.
I've got a machine, Linux host.
Again, the message I'm
trying to drive home
is, this should be normal.
I do a show mount, and I can see
the exported file systems off
of that machine.
I'm going to make a
directory and mount one.
Got it.
Move into it.
There's nothing in there.
Let me copy some data in.
So standard commands,
copying data over.
These things can be more
difficult with Cloud Storage,
very easy with NFS.
All right.
So I'm going to look at a file.
So I'm showing file
ownership, ACLs.
This is POSIX information.
File ownership, all
of the attributes,
we maintain all of that intact--
mtime, atime, ctime,
ACLs, everything works.
We just changed it.
The integrity is there.
It just works.
Look familiar?
Bingo.
Next topic-- what
about resizing?
What if I need to change that?
Coming out of storage world,
if you've done work in SAN,
this is always a big problem,
any block-based systems.
The nice thing about NFS is
you can change your mind really
quickly without really
any sort of an impact.
So to make the change,
either go into the GUI
or throw a command
through the API.
Give it a new size.
We go from 10 gigabytes
here to 2,000 gigabytes.
Update it.
And that's already been
propagated to the VM.
We'll do a DF again.
You'll see right on the bottom
we went from 10 gigabytes
here to 2 terabytes available.
Easy answer to "I'm
running out of capacity"
as a problem for the end user.
In fact, we can vastly
over-provision the system.
We'll just do this
one to be cute.
We'll go from 2 terabytes
to 20 terabytes.
We can move into petabyte
range if we wanted to.
So kind of create your
destiny the way you want it.
And then let you can
let your capacity--
the actual allocation doesn't
have to be made until you start
running out of capacity.
So I could have a
3-terabyte cluster
that grows into those sizes.
Snapshots-- snapshots are
amazing if you use them
in development
process for whatever
reasons-- restoring files
or keeping multiple versions
of a database or something.
We built that right
into the system here.
So I'll show you a manual
way to take a snapshot.
And again, same caveat--
this can all be automated
through API calls
or other command line functions.
So snapshot's in place.
I think we are on
the other demo.
Let me skip ahead.
All right.
I don't have the snapshot
one in, but snapshots take--
we use a dot snapshot directory
at the root of every export,
so all the snapshots
that are taken there
are then made available.
And those snapshots can then,
you can access them and mount
them directly, or you
can replicate those off
to another site like
I'll show you here.
And the second alternative
is to use CloudConnect
to mount a snapshot,
and move that data
to other platforms like GCS.
And so a quick sneak peek, if
you have to Elastifile systems
or more set up, we can create
a replication relationship,
asynchronous replication
to other sites.
So this would be used if you
have an Elastifile on-prem,
I can use this to connect
through a VPN tunnel
to Google Cloud.
And I can replicate data up
there and make it accessible
and the like.
And we can go bidirectional
and all of that.
All right.
So there's a quick
overview of the tech
and all the great
capabilities in there.
There's a lot more
than that, but I
wanted to, again,
drive the point home
that we're trying to create
a place almost like a hotel
experience.
It's a home away from home
as you start to figure out,
how am I going to
get into Cloud?
So I want to now hand
the mic over to Naidu.
He's been leading
the team over there
at eSilicon for many years,
a pioneer in their industry.
And they've been breaking
glass as they figured out
how to take advantage of
Cloud in the EDA space.
So without further, Naidu.
NAIDU ANNAMANENI:
Thank you, Dave.
DAVE PAYNE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
NAIDU ANNAMANENI: eSilicon
is an advanced chip and IP
provider for
tier-one system OEMs,
like the Cisco's of the world,
for high-performance computing,
networking, the
AI and 5G market.
So we have been in business
since 2000, developed
over 300 chips into production.
And our current focus is on
[INAUDIBLE],, leading edge
60-nanometer and below.
So the ongoing work is
on the 7-nanometer stuff.
That is the bleeding edge.
So our unique capabilities
are, so we are only
supplier in the world.
We are firmly agnostic.
We don't care whether it's
the [INAUDIBLE] or Samsung.
We have chips in both foundries.
And we use big data to
optimize the chip design.
Before even the design
starts, we estimate big data
based on hundreds of terabytes
of data, the IP libraries.
So what is the optimal power,
performance, and [INAUDIBLE]??
So that's our
unique capabilities
and differentiation
in the marketplace.
So Dean and Dave talked about
Google Compute and Storage,
right?
So what are the
business challenges
that we are trying to address?
So in chip design,
during the tapeout phase,
typical compute and storage
requirements are 2 to 4x more.
So we have in our private
cloud about 12,000 cores
during these high-end designs.
But one of the chips that
required about 30,000
cores six months
before the tapeout.
So about a year ago, we
partnered with Google
to see that, rather than going
and building another 30,000
more cores, which
is more expensive,
we already went into data
center as a service about three
years ago.
And there is no capex to build.
We are in the opex model.
But the current issue
with the current provider
is that every time we
need more capacity,
they need a long-term commit.
That's not going to scale given
the technology that we are in
[INAUDIBLE].
So partnered with Google.
And the other
challenge we had was,
when you cluster the tapeout,
you cannot rewrite over flows,
design flows.
This takes years, right?
So for us, the current design
flow, we built it for 18 years.
So it means that within
six-month window,
we need to scale from 10,000
cores to the 20,000 more cores.
And the last one is that
our IP development is always
one [? load ?] ahead.
And their compute
requirements, again,
is exponentially higher
to several thousand cores,
from a few hundred
to a thousand cores.
So let's see how we did it.
This is a truly hybrid cloud.
And our engineers, we have 700
engineers around the world.
They come to our data center
to do the normal flow using
the same UI, so that that's
where they come to the layout
and run their jobs.
They don't see anything
on the right side.
We have configured
a couple of queues.
1G internet connection through
the VPN for the NFS traffic
to the Google Cloud, and 100-meg
line for the administrative,
like starting the VMs, starting
the jobs, and so forth.
So one of the attractive
things on the Google side
was, Google has a concept
called preemptible VMs.
That comes with no
commitment, 80% discount
on the regular VMs.
That was very attractive to us
when we started the journey.
And we engineered such that--
the chip development, one of
the chips that we targeted this,
we had 30,000 cores are
needed for the chip tapeout.
The storage is about 700
terabytes-- one chip.
So we possibly cannot
have that, right?
So that's where the [INAUDIBLE]
based file system, over a year
ago it was not scaling.
That's when we partnered
with Dave's company.
We were able to use their
Elastifile in the hybrid cloud.
Truly, whatever the results
are they are locally stored.
And thinking back to
the results today,
small subset today
are our private cloud.
The other business unit where
we have the IP development,
we don't use any of
the local storage.
It's completely remote NFS.
They are small.
Thousands of cores,
even now we have
running several thousand cores.
Continuous results are remote
NFS to our private cloud.
Again, 90% of the workloads
use Google's preemptible VMs.
So with respect-- you know,
Dave talked about lots
of slides, lots of demos.
In one project, we were about
to an eight-node cluster
with a couple of
hundred terabytes.
And the other project,
three-node cluster.
So it scales.
The guy, David, is
the key architect
on our side, closely worked
with the [INAUDIBLE] team.
So the whole thing
took from [INAUDIBLE]
to production deployment.
Within three months, we
were able to scale from zero
to 20,000 cores.
One business unit,
another business unit,
another 10,000 cores, within
three-months time frame.
You know, so what are some
of the lessons learned
during those three months
[INAUDIBLE] process?
The PDKs and tools, these
are all terabytes of data.
So we cannot be remote NFS.
So we have a local storage
in the Google Cloud.
The other one is that on-prem
we are able to get results.
That is where some of the
customization is needed.
Terabytes of data cannot
be back and forth,
even if you have a 10-gig or
100-gig line in case it won't.
So we modified our flow to
only a small subset of the data
to sync back to
the private cloud.
And storage is still expensive.
We have Google [INAUDIBLE]
and these guys on the Cloud.
So we were very aggressive
in cleaning up the data,
rather than keeping
it for months.
Because the intermediate results
are only kept for a week or so,
and then the actual
results of the small subset
is synced back to
our private cloud.
Again, the other
thing is that the way
it stands on the cloud for a
chip design or complex chip
design like ours,
physical disks won't work.
The SSD we learned the long way.
We started with
the physical disk.
It wasn't scaling.
Then we had to go with all SSDs.
And then like we talked
about, the NFS traffic
is on a separate line, and
then the administrative traffic
is on a different line.
These are the key
lessons learned.
And even today, we
are the only company
that does the full physical
design on the Cloud.
Yeah, that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVE PAYNE: Yeah, I really
appreciate that presentation,
Naidu.
That was a fun project
to work on together,
and very impressive
what we could do--
30,000 cores just
like that, right?
And what are you doing
with those cores now?
DEAN HILDEBRAND:
Other great things.
DAVE PAYNE: Other
great things, yeah.
They're being reused
somewhere else.
That's amazing, right?
The ability to stand
up an infrastructure
that big and that complex in
that short amount of time,
and then only pay for what
you use, is pretty impressive.
And that's really,
I think Cloud,
I'm seeing with
the customer base
out there in
different companies,
it's just changing
the way that you work.
The fundamentals are different.
So I can do short-term
things as needed,
pay for exactly what I need,
and get really customized.
It's a lot of bespoke
opportunities in Cloud.
But it's also
becoming a nice place
to rest as your final
home, if you will,
and run applications out there.
So I wanted to do a shout out
to one of our team members.
You don't know him,
but you should.
His name is Ronan Cohen.
He's one of the
wizards at Elastifile
that did a lot of the work to
make these demos come together
for us.
This is the dress code at
Elastifile, by the way.
You must wear pointy coned hats.
Lastly, to bring it all back
together, no yak shaving.
Now, I can't say that
there won't be any.
Of course there will be.
That's what we do.
It's our jobs.
But we're trying
to do is take yet
another bunch of labor
out of the process
to get into Cloud--
things that really
don't create a lot of value.
Building out file systems
and learning how to do ZFS
or whatever it might be, it
just doesn't add a lot of value
to the bottom line when
your boss or your business
or your organization
is saying, I
need to get to the
financial benefits of Cloud.
I need time matters,
money matters.
Let's move.
We're trying to take those
things out of the way
so you can move faster.
Again, going back
to what Dean said.
It's not about the
hardware and the protocol.
They're actually agnostic.
You can use them in Cloud.
It's about let's use
them the right way,
and we can move faster.
So it's all about acceleration.
What we're trying to do
is present an opportunity
to make it easy
to lift and shift
or to burst or to move
permanently into Cloud,
and be able to take some of the
applications that really demand
a lot more than is typical.
In my career over the last 15,
20 years, the early adopters
in Cloud were mostly either
pure web applications
or secondary storage and DR and
backup and things like that.
I think the world
has really shifted.
We can do full-production,
high-performance workloads,
really intense stuff.
And I think Cloud
is starting to meet
not only the functional
requirements, but the security
requirements to
get there, as well.
So remember Elastifile-- Cloud
native NFS, single-click,
let it go.
Follow the link on the
bottom in the marketplace,
and you can get started today.
Thank you.
Come see us.
We're over in the Moscone south.
Stop by.
We've got a whole
team over there.
We'd love to chat
with you some more.
OK?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]